[Applause]
[Music]
okay cool let's do it boys Steve I'm
inviting what so what's the most we got
tonight three oh we two and a half
all right dude we know we know this is a
gentleman for those of you who are still
here this is the real [ __ ] right this is
when the team really shines and you'll
see you just watch we're gonna do great
we gotta beat three guys that's what we
gotta be has did everyone recent what
are you talking about
don't worry no I didn't long Terrace
there goes good together right guys
you're in your bath you could you know
we'd remember that one night till 4:00
in the morning we killed it yeah well
I'm not staying up until 4:00 in the
morning I got general Steven charge okay
this is it this is what wfe really
shines okay let's work together I'm
counting on you we got northern Cali my
rock and southern California working in
unison and it's just nothing but good
place so who's the leader Craig and your
general Steve no yeah no no don't listen
to me man go to castle work together
team shoot if it looks busy a castle and
running around the hatch easy-peasy okay
team shoot cover each other's back
mm-hmm banana wake up and Anna we need
you bro
Stevie there I'm a week yeah what you
gonna post a picture of that portrait
that's Stevie Drew of you bro I will no
no he's talking about banana a banana a
picture Oh Pikachu Leoben an alone the
fortress fortress oh yeah I see it I see
it you did pose
oh no we're getting D dog looks miss
screens black oh no leave the ship wait
a second those New Zealand dudes again
it could be Pikachu are you kind of a
moan no this is a bad sign maybe I
should just cuz Craig's here
I'm just China yeah boy oh okay outside
you likes leading make some feel
important over there they went to go
into catch how'd you come around the
back
hurry up come on you're safe now and
catch here we go you guys go outside
right here go Scooby
where's tortilla pica he's heard autumn
down there's another one inside there we
go you better cut this out Oh a dog [ __ ]
oh we gotta communicate oh no this isn't
a real wfe now people will see let's go
ahead here they are go Pikachu right
behind you on your six alright let's
come castle-like left look right all
right no good to have you get the heavy
honey don't don't no enough time I'm
getting hurt they're pushing up on you
you're dead I know it's too late a snake
who's got the heavy they took it they
have the heavy it just said it said it
I don't want to set it cuz we gotta get
killed see there's my good Stevie get
somebody up get somebody up not me come
back come back
alright hold on guys we gotta stick
together everybody ran yeah
whatever I say ignore it and listen to
Craig just listen to me this is we're
gonna go to castle I'm with you Craig
where are the other guys yep break off
here we go alright guys it's a little
middle well guys I need to teach you
that guy's almost dead in there he's in
that tunnel Stevie I died oh my god
oh this is a very sick man well we gotta
focus on the same guy if there's two
guys I know but I had a guy that was
almost dead shouldn't a guy to left can
we push this guy start a plan let's go
to castle this planet this is terrible
I'm watching a planet planet planet boom
alright
they're gonna come down left here back
up back up oh do they attack me I know
help you guys yeah back up the other guy
get the other guy I need help
there you go he's right there
I died Oh get him don't let him don't
let him get it
just don't fight him don't find he's
behind you you see your left mind you
excited if your name you got it you got
it you got it all right that was better
no I just got a little better yeah
exactly that's all you have to do I'm
gonna kill you did good banana Thanks
well they're gonna pry it let's go all
right there I'm here castle Greg yeah
but all right let's go
middle by three Stevie back up back up
Stevie Stevie regroup
don't forget
oh no you went through the window Oh
Craig is behind you
Wow God man I'm just getting I don't
know where everybody's going you know
let's just I didn't I was staying at
castle and then they shot me from the
tunnel all right all right let's go
together we go catch catch us too easy
for them because they already start in
here get them thought I'm we're good
we're good we're good we're good watch
our down
there you go get that guy hey no one guy
left
don't run Pikachu are you going why are
you chasing him just stay with use it
defuse it
no no what happened here what the hell
man just get out of there and just keep
them off them keep them off give them on
the bomb and we can win it's over we
can't win no no we can win but we got a
we got a like play smarter I Pikachu
you're running off I saw you run away
from the hole gir gotta stay with them
okay so join me [ __ ] first castle
yeah I think Pikachu sometimes doesn't
stuff to aggravate me
all right there Oh back Oh
[ __ ] a [ __ ] work [ __ ]
it's a warm-up all right how do we lose
to three guys
but we didn't win one so we're good yeah
we can still go we gotta work together
huh because you guys jinxed it you said
New Zealand I will say right now Pikachu
you were not following us a lot of time
hey don't blame him hey we mean let's go
okay let's clear the car oh no we can
still go right yeah we know he does this
all the time when we play now we have
more viewers when we're getting our
asses kicked 17 now it's 26 this is
Hornets like bad for the channel you
know what I mean it's great up to the
name we got B point well you know what's
right I just leave it at that we we know
we know the real what happened last week
we know the real so let's do this so
that wasn't as bad
yeah we won't hear the good news -
getting these guys is you're all good
people and that counts for something
hey good people thank you it's your
phone the phone I'm telling you just put
in your phone you gotta put it far away
because you keep looking at it and it's
distance from you so if you could bring
it over here weird pictures on there you
might not want to see I'm not I don't
care about your dick pics
[Laughter]
why does everyone Gilbert Gilbert I did
finally we've actually done good when
were you when we play together
but we have to like support each other
what do you see the hard light what's
the other gun time war inspired these
guys like I haven't what are you talking
about no we have not okay okay there
they seem good it doesn't matter what
they look like you're right dude you're
right dude we beat that one team that
was like all right hi let's do this
castle let's play it car Wow
the one of their players message me you
said back out so you don't ruin your
negative Katie
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] talking [ __ ]
dude yeah fine do you have people like
that should not be able to even play the
game that's when I wish we do have a
coke on that's a dick move dude okay
what do you say what do you say hey dude
that's like the past there's a new team
he was talking [ __ ] - [ __ ] vulgar no
these guys are talking [ __ ] too vulgar
what were they saying backed out back
outs they don't ruin your negative KT
that guy's [ __ ] hurt I'm down you
guys old town [ __ ] this - no no [ __ ]
this guy over just one right I know I
know
[ __ ] these guys I'm beyond you
Baram Oh Carla
they're both right there which is remind
us you get hurt nice he's pushing that's
all right well we got three of them down
there talking all this [ __ ]
we still got almost all of them down
sorry guys sorry I didn't mean to lose
my : watch out they're fast
I killed electro oh let's go in the room